[Music]
it's everyone's favorite fruit it's
everyone's favorite sport it's a
watermelon seed spitting contest not
only is it the most competitive event at
your County Fair but it might also be
the most dangerous ever wondered what
would happen if you accidentally
swallowed a watermelon seed could a
watermelon vine grow in your stomach how
could something so small survive the
destructive pool of acid that sits in
your stomach how big would it grow and
would growing fruit in your body mean
you'd never have to make another trip to
the market or would it result in a very
long stay in the hospital this is what
if and here's what would happen if seeds
could grow in your stomach it doesn't
happen often but seeds can grow inside
you a 28 year old Russian man who went
to the hospital complaining of chest
pain was rushed into surgery when
doctors discovered a five centimeter fir
tree growing in his lung and in
Massachusetts a 75 year old man was also
treated for a growth in his lung after a
pea seed in his food went down the wrong
tube but to survive and thrive in a
habitat as hostile as your stomach it
would have to be one really determined
seed your stomach secretes enzymes and
hydrochloric acid that break down any
food you swallow and it kills any
harmful microbes that might have hitched
a ride in the hydrochloric acid in your
stomach is so strong that it even poses
a risk to the organist
this is why your stomach also secretes a
mucus it lines your stomach walls so
that the acid doesn't burn through
so if any seed has a chance of surviving
your stomach it's going to have to adapt
and evolve and fast unfortunately you'll
feel every grip and blow of this
biological grudge match so prepare for
the worst stomach ache of your life you
may never eat another piece of fruit
again in a world where seeds could
easily grow in your stomach
the demand for seedless fruits and
vegetables would skyrocket even if it
meant the price of produce would jump
because of the extra time it would take
to remove every little seed people would
rather pay more or not at all for the
privilege of not turning into a fruit
tree this would be a world in which
seeds have adapted to grow much faster
than ever before since it normally takes
several weeks for a seed to germinate
while the stomach digests its food
within a few hours seeds need warmth
moisture and oxygen to germinate and
you'll find all that in the stomach but
you'll also find hydrochloric acid the
hydrochloric acid would have no trouble
dissolving a seeds protective coating
which would allow the seed to absorb
some water and start to grow the seed
would then move on to the duodenum which
is the start of your small intestine
this is where your body starts to absorb
vitamins minerals and other nutrients
inside the duodenum it's dark and moist
with neutral pH levels the first sprouts
from a seed could grow here but they
would need to be tough enough to survive
the intestinal juices assuming that the
plant growing inside you could survive
this intestinal assault it might steal
some of the nutrients you're trying to
digest and if the plant were able to get
enough nutrients it might even start to
grow flowers and produce fruit
hopefully you would have gone to the
hospital long before this point because
with branches flowers and fruit growing
inside you the pain would be unbearable
and it would only get worse plants
typically grow towards the Sun would
they try to grow their way out of us to
catch some rays or would they continue
to take nutrients from the other foods
we digest would we start to form a
symbiotic relationship with the plant
where we'd give it some nutrients it
would grow fruit and we digest it and
blow the new seeds if that's the case
you'd better be extra careful about
which seeds you swallow some of them
like the apple seed are toxic apples
along with more than 2,000 other plant
species produce cyanogenic glycosides in
large doses they can cause cyanide
poisoning neurological disorder and
delay or slow growth the best thing you
could do in a world where seeds can grow
in your stomach is not to eat any seeds
under any circumstances pay the extra
money for the seedless fruit put your
life before your pride and walk away
from that seed spitting contest you'll
thank us later when you're not a walking
watermelon
luckily we don't live in a world where
that's a risk the possibility of seeds
germinating and growing in the stomach
is zero while there have been rare cases
of plants growing in the lungs the
stomach is much too harsh an environment
for any seat to survive there
but speaking of harsh environments we've
got a new show that focuses on just that
and it might even save your life one day
have you ever wondered if it's possible
to survive something as deadly as a
solar storm well we've got tips on that
and more in our new show how to survive
[Music]
you
you